TOY.
ERIC.
THANKSSO CH.
DanaM SU E GOVEORS
ARIZA AND ANN JU.ER BOER PATR EN
SEMA.
WANT HEAR OUT YOUR
CISI FOE RD PAOL.
YOU VED THE JOB BUT  HA
ANGE
>> S, E LA YEAR --FO
YEARS I LOVEE JO
I LOD WHATI WAS ING
FORCING E LAAND THLAST
IN E LASTYE I WAMORE
DISGNTLE
COMING T.I WANOHAPPGOING TO RK.
WE SWE ON TH TOOTECT THE BOER DO
WS.
IT DOESN'T TTERPUBLICANOR
MOCR INOFFICE,  SHLD
BEDOINTH AND WEHAVEN'T
BE DOG THAT.
I D LIKEOTHE HAVE
>> na: I WA TO K YOU
OTHEQUESON BEFO T
BRDON.
HAVEYOU EV SEEN TUATN
LIKE IS?
, HAN'T.
VE NOSE THMORA IS
D.
ISNOT ST AS  STATN
IT WAROUGUTTHE BOER
TROL EVYWHE.
U W OPLE WHJUSTWEN'HAY WI WH'S .
WEE RIING R LIVEEVER
DAY TCHI MAN ANDRUG
ITWAS SL  THE CE TO US
Da: I' GET RIT BA
YO
BRDON,YOU'VE EN YING
NOBUT ES ITELLI IT IS
REHING SO SOROF VER
PIH?
THINIT GOODTHE CRETY
NT WN  THE RDERTOLK
TO TH ATLEAST STENBUWHENHEES BAO
WAINON  DON'T EM LIKE
ANYTNG ANS ANWE'RW
PRESENCY, SO TOBE th.
D THING ISGOING TO
CHAN.
IF YOLOOKGHT W STATION
DE, NAONWI, THE IS SO
CH ANR,SO CH FRUSTRATN
YOU N GO  ANY BORD PATR
TENSION.TUALLY FE TH
EVERSILE TIME A S.
CITIN OVDOSES WEFEELIT
ERY ME A S. CITIN  HAED  ANILLE
OSSEWE EL .
WE WA  PROTT E ERAN
BLICBUT OUR HANDARTIED
CAUS POLITICA
ASPITIONAND FRKLY TIED
BEUSE OF CAREERASPITIONS
THEYWA TO DO IS MO UP.
AT'S WRG,  NT
OTECTHE AMERIC PUBL BU
RIGHNOW  JU CAN' IT.
SITUION WE ULD CEIF YO
HAD RE OF THAGEN MAKE A
DESION LI YOVE DONETO
LEAVTHBOER TR EN
OUGHYOLOVETHJOB T NOT
JOYOU EL TH YOU N DO
ANLOOKYOSELFINTHE RROR
ATNIGHOWG AT YOU
AREN'TALLOD TO WH YO
ARE PPOS   DOING?
VERY DAEROUNIT WI BE
WEE THSANDOF AGEN ORT.
WENEED MO PEOPLEAVIN
WE'RE T REACG THAGEN
THAT ARE LEAVING.
BOER BYEMSELVESILEOFN
WA'T PPENING FOUR YES
AGO.
DOT WANT  T POTICA
BUT R TRUMHE WAS LLIN
TOREACH OUD SPEATOUS
THE SOURCES WE EDEDAND
WHEVERWE NEED TODO OUR
GETTG ANYTHI. AR'T
ABOUE UKRAINE BORD AN
OUR OWN SOHE RDER
FE NOAS THE BOER  GREATE
COINTOBEOPEN KE TH?
AGENTS I RK WI.FELLOW
I WOY ABOUTHEM.
T LY THR SAFE  E
FIELBUT MEAL.ITIS A TOH JOB ANR
NOHANG THE SUPPT OFYO
PER MANAMENTINUDIN
IEF ORTID HIER UPIN
E MINIRATI MAKES
VERY DIFFULT.
BEINHERETH ROSEMARY FO
WE VE TAVE IT THE.
SEMARY NGRALATIS ON
MANGA TOUG